alors je savais pas que les chasseurs
passé
et à plein de gens sur twitter me dit
cyril il faut sortir un petit peu de la
ville les chasseurs voilà l'on quitte
henry voilà donc toile apparemment voilà
donc oui oui y'a que gilles verdez
continent voilà ils préfèrent voilà la
veille gilles fouad al alagui les bars
et vous merci non mais alors gilles
verdez pourquoi non ne touchez pas aux
chasseurs les chasseurs sont exemplaires
dans leur immense majorité
et là il ya quelques bobos des sénateurs
qui disent sur des territoires privés on
va les empêcher de prendre l'apéro avant
d'aller chasser etc mais franchement
c'est honteux ils ne font rien de mal
heureusement qu'ils sont là ils tuent
des êtres la prolifération des sangliers
auraient au printemps capeyron ne
touchez pas aux chasseurs et non
chasseurs ne sont pas bourré
chasseurs à ça c'est un chasseur est
tombé doit savoir chasser son gainsbourg
si vous m'appelez dit c'est pour ça
bah oui mais un kata tu verras
là on est là dedans
[Applaudissements]
mais gilles qui dit font rien de mal
enfin pardon mais chassez ces gammes
tuer des animaux pour le plaisir
hervé l'espace loisirs des prix le sont
aussi pour le plaisir ou sud est une
aberration qu'on autorise ça si en plus
on pouvait leur éviter d'être ivre quand
y tiennent une arme à feu ce serait
comme une bonne chose peut-être que s'il
arrête de boire ils n'auront plus envie
de chasser donc franchement c'est une
bonne chose
on tirait sur un chevreuil un samedi
matin
est-ce que sache quand même qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup malheureusement alors
c'est la mauvaise par tim de des
chasseurs qui tient sur leurs chiens et
sert à reconnaître là parce que
c'est un peu la grande vadrouille
peu compliqué quand il y un an les deux
bobos
sortie par jamais aller à la campagne
qui se monte à 2,9 à l'achat finalement
fait mourir il était
monté toi tu en mets
dans le top 5 des chasseurs d'accord oui
bénin débat c'est pas pour ou contre la
bien sûr c'est pourquoi des chasseurs
bout et ne fait pas sans stigmatiser
sans dire tous les chasseurs chasse ivre
mort c'est pas la questionnant frappe à
pau contre des chirurgiens esthétiques
et jeudi
soir tarifs 10 ans auteur pas voilà ils
sont contre non nous mais bien des
éthylotests ont conduit et en disant
c'est le conduisait vous risquez de
faire des actions agressives étudie le
dossier risque énorme et vous et ça se
reproduit démission démission
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait des fiches projets et
arrondies n'a pas pansé ses lattes de
connaître les gens et pas aussi beaux
jeans les gendarmes contrôlent alors
quand il roule morale collines les
pareil il enlevait sa soeur est contrôlé
au volant tout court est contrôlé et
crétin
à l'énerver ont bel et bien la chasse
sur des territoires prix mais maman dans
le public on est donc dans une forêt
privée oui mais quelqu'un parce qu'on
est bourré non parce que c'est une forêt
privée
les chasseurs ne sent pas bon ribéry
l'a fait travailler je suis à travailler
tu sait à combien les plombs on voit
combien de balles peut aller encore il
faut que tu as tiré à ce fait une erreur
de ma part - des privés je t'explique
n'a une solide avance à petit pas que
100% une chasse au loup mais je parle
d'un principe de précaution si tu veux
prendre l'apéro battu le prend à 19
heures il faut que tu as fini ta journée
de chasse avec tes camarades
jamais chasser on prend la métropole on
va chasser bellaingeois elle fait tout
gris métal a dit ça
[Applaudissements]
non
mais là il m'a fait tout et ballack a dû
venir à bas la sacem à la gay pride à va
chez le dentiste est déroulé les 12
hommes c'est wonder woman oui vous avez
pardonnez moi mais je pense que j'ai la
raison d'être un petit peu dans la
caricature vous présenter les chasseurs
comme des espèces de gros beaufs non pas
d'une union qui dit bon allez on s'en
met un coup et après on va les tuer bon
du tout avec moi c'est pas mal ça tu ne
savent pas ce qu'est prête non c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe ouais tu es bon
million de chasseurs aujourd'hui en
france qu'en unissant ce qu'on est en
droit d'aller soutenir par exemple est
ce que vous savez combien il ya eu leurs
deux chats il ya eu 30 millions d'heures
de chasse ok oui
combien ils eurent à cause de l'alcool
de mort c'est zéro mais c'est depuis
mais mon visage peu nommé convenu de
méfait en fait non en fait là n'existe
pas je pense qu'ils sont quand même
suffisamment éduqués pour ce quand même
pour se réguler pour moi éventuellement
après mais pas avant ils sont là
complètement abouti en fait alors longs
bas noir et ça vient ça sent pas la
question c'est que j'ai un problème oui
très arrosée pour ça les payer pour dire
ça
c'est normal
on a un spécialiste de la colle et missy
je sais
ça sera bourré ya forcément des mecs qui
font la paire aud avant de chasser et
oui excusez moi mais la vérité mais
panda n'y a pas eu d'accident